- It's in everyone's comments,
but all these fuck faces
listening right now
care more about the
likes people give them,
than the people behind those likes.
(hip hop music)
(whistle blows)
- [Man] The hardest part is figuring out
what you want to master.
- [Man] Focus on your product.
- [Man] Can you tell
somebody that they suck?
- [Man] You gotta just go for it.
- [Man] This is exactly what
I wanna do for a living.
- [Man] You can't even tell somebody
that their breath stinks.
- All right, ladies and
gentlemen we are back
with a very, very, very,
very, very special guest.
I would argue to say your
favorite entrepreneur's
favorite entrepreneur, Gary Vee.
- Thanks for having me.
- Welcome, man.
Thanks for making this happen.
- That was a lot of verys.
I'm fired up, I'm like a seven very guy.
- Well, I'm gonna be honest.
You're so like, just like
everyone's favorite dude
that I always say tell
me who you'd like to hear
on this thing, and I get
a lot of good suggestions,
but every time there's a Gary Vee ask.
- That's awesome.
- So I wanted to give you the
appropriate amount of verys.
- I appreciate it, I'm humbled.
Thank you, audience.
Let's kill this.
- You're really connecting.
So let me...
You know what I do on this is I usually go
through people's stories, right?
I know we have a limited amount of time,
and I know you've talked about it a lot
so I want to try to kind
of get through it quick,
but you grew up in Belarus.
- Yes.
- How old were you when you moved?
- Three, so I didn't really...
- So you don't really remember?
- I was born in Belarus.
I grew up in...
I really grew up in Edison, New Jersey.
I spent a little time in Queens
when we first came to America.
Studio apartment similar to
the room we're in right now.
Lot of family members.
Some real ghetto shit.
But where I really made my
hay and really became like...
Where I grew up was Edison, New Jersey
which was great in the '80s.
Super diverse, lots of everything.
Asian and brown and black and white.
It was really, really cool that way.
It was the '80s so everybody was outside.
You know, like when I
was six, I ate breakfast,
I went outside at 8:30,
9:00, I came home for lunch,
I went back outside, I came home at 7:00.
And we were out.
- And what were you doing?
Did you ever, like, I know
you're into basketball.
Did you play basketball?
What was your life like?
- Basketball came later.
A lot of Nerf football,
a lot of wiffle ball,
a lot of wallball, a lot of tennis,
for that kind of shit but you
know, as I like to tell it
and like the friends that
have were around back then
I was forced, like we did Olympics.
We played spud, which was this weird game
where you'd hit the ball on the ground
but like we did kids stuff.
But man we did a lot of business,
like a lot of lemonade stands,
a lot of like raking peoples leaves,
a lot of selling flowers,
a lot of baseball cards,
like just a lot...
I've been addicted to the
game of entrepreneurship
from the get.
So I would say 50% of the time
it was some cockamamie business thing
and 50% of time of that other 50
like wiffle ball and
football were way up there.
- And was that, like the other
kids were doing that too,
doing the the young hustler stuff?
- I was making them.
I was definitely the force.
- And this is what...
have you ever wrapped
your head around like
what drove you to go that direction?
- DNA, like just the same way
somebody starts fucking
drawing at six and never stops.
- Yeah.
- Right?
Like the same reason
somebody just starts singing
and never stops.
Or you know, I think there's
a small group of people,
call it three to 20% of people
who are just deeply
passionate about their thing.
Maybe it's even less, maybe 10% of people
who are just like I'm incapable
of being anything else.
I got lucky and I hate the word luck
but like I'm living through a time
where entrepreneurship is cool.
Like if you're a businessman in 1974,
like you know the Knicks
players don't think you're cool.
Like you know in 1983
like Russell Simmons doesn't think
that the CEO of IBM is the fucking shit.
Like that's just not how it was.
So what's been really crazy for me is like
I lived a life, I was 30 years
old, like I was 34 years old
before I made one
business video in my life.
So I'd already built a business.
My family's liquor store business.
I had already, like I lived a life.
I was 34, I lived a life
before all this shit started happening.
And just watching the
entrepreneurship be put on a pedestal
is exciting and also scary.
I will tell you that one of
the number one fears I have is
too many kids want to be an entrepreneur
even though they're not.
- That's what's
interesting is because like
I think that entrepreneurship
is having a moment
and also you're like
directly out in front of it.
You know I mean?
Like it's having a moment
and you are the guy.
You know I mean?
Do you know how many people,
how many meetings I go into now
and everyone now has a camera guy?
- Oh yeah.
- And that's literally 100% I think,
influenced by what you're doing.
But my question is so
obviously that's cool
and that's the discussion
that a lot of people
have on this podcast is like yeah,
everyone's a entrepreneur now.
And I say I think that the good news is
there will be more real
entrepreneurs out of this, right?
There's just going to be a lot of fakers.
- To your point, net.
There are thousands, tens of thousands,
and I would argue hundreds of thousands
and maybe even millions
who during this era
find entrepreneurship, the
freedoms that come with it,
the beauty of it that
wouldn't have 20 years ago
because there would have been executives.
What I'm worried about
is the collateral damage.
- What do you think happens to the person
that's caught in the crossfire?
- I think there's some
people that commit suicide.
I think there's some people that...
you have to understand why I say that.
Depression because you can't hide.
Like when your T-shirt business fails
'cause the economy fails
and influencers don't get
paid like that anymore
and shit hits the fan and
you go work at Citibank,
your family and friends know.
And don't forget you're the one who...
you know like all this--
- It was in your bio.
- Yeah man this is super documented.
Like you're talking shit 26
months ago in front of a Lambo
and now you work at Chick-fil-a corporate.
And that's gonna be
something that's gonna take
a lot of self-esteem and
humility to get through
and most people haven't been raised
with self-esteem and humility.
So the reason I'm talking
this game is not to be like
I'm cool and you're not.
It's like yo, you know
what's fucking cool?
Self-awareness.
You know what the fucking
coolest shit in the game is?
Forget like fresh sneakers
and forget like a hoodie
and forget about money
and forget about being a
cryptocurrency fucking winner.
You know what's the fucking coolest?
Self-awareness.
Do you know yourself?
And then do you put yourself
in the best position to succeed?
- Yeah, so what would
the advice be to someone,
if someone's listening
right now who is like damn,
I've been talking a lot of
shit on Instagram and I'm not--
- Go work for somebody.
- Well but what I'm saying is,
let's just say you're trying to
get your business off the ground,
to be determined whether it
ends up becoming successful--
- People know.
People know, right?
- The entrepreneur knows.
- Listen, if you're listening right now.
You're like fuck, I don't want...
I just tweeted something
that just went kind of batshit crazy.
It went something like
yo, if you're 22 years old
and your parents pay for
any part of your lifestyle,
let me define that real quick.
If your parents pay for your Uber,
if your parents pay for your gym,
if they're splitting the rent with you,
if they pay for your
fucking shit in any way.
Does your mommy and
daddy give you a dollar?
If they do and you talk shit
about them to your friends
that they're not giving you more,
you're the biggest piece
of shit of all time.
So I put that out there, right?
And so it's getting crazy right now
and some people are coming through,
they're like yo, this is the thing
I'm most embarrassed about.
And I'm like yo, change.
I'm like good.
First of all you're amazing
because a lot of people are seeing that
and saying fuck you Gary Vee, you know?
Good, you're like yes, that's me.
Change.
Like is it gonna be fun that you
maybe can't wear a pair of
Yeezys as often as you want?
Is it fun that you can't
take out your girl to
the fanciest fucking spot?
Is it fun like you know,
you want the new LeBrons
or you want better tickets
to the fucking playoff game
or you want to get a bottle at the club,
like is it fun that you can't?
No but is it way better
and putting you in a position
to succeed long-term?
Absolutely because when you're
living in a fake environment
and that's what's happening right now.
The thing that I'm getting
most passionate about is
fake environments.
Too much money in the
system, fake environment.
Influencers getting paid for everything
like chick, like that
is an inflated market
that will eventually have to correct.
The number one fake
environment in our society is
you think you're a big shot
but your parents are
actually paying for it.
I fucking hate those people.
- So let me ask you what the heck is this,
'cause this is the lesson I'm
kind of gathering from that--
- Actually real quick
'cause I need clarity.
I don't hate those people.
I hate those people if they talk shit,
make pretend they're not getting paid for,
or talk shit about their parents.
If you walk around like yo, my
parents are the fucking best
and I'm actually really
untitled but like fuck it,
this is my life.
If you own your shit, I love you.
- Yeah, so that's my question is
'cause you're all about creating content
and putting everything out there,
is it just don't front?
Put everything out
there but tell the truth
and say like yo, today's vlog,
my mom just pay my phone bill.
That's dope but I'm really
trying to grind it out.
- Yes.
Dude, people will love you for that.
Like when you say a
lot of people like you,
I hear that and I'm like
because I like them first.
'Cause I'm not trying to get like...
Do you know how many
people on the Internet
are faking a lifestyle
so that people pay them?
- [Chris] Yeah, oh yeah.
The whole Internet.
- The whole Internet.
Like the whole Internet right
now is faking a lifestyle
and then trying to sell people on like
I figured out this lifestyle, you can too.
When they didn't figure out that lifestyle
and their business is
to make money off you.
- [Chris] Yeah, of course.
- Whether that's selling a
course or selling a product.
- Yeah, I'm curious what
that correction will be.
There's always a correction,
what's that correction?
- When the economy fucking
fails and people look around,
be like yo, where's the money?
You know everybody under 30
hasn't been punched in the face yet.
- Yes, true.
That's very true.
- Like unless you lived through 2008,
which is now a decade ago,
you haven't been punched in the mouth.
And until you're punched in the mouth,
you actually don't know how tough you are.
- True.
Okay, let me ask you this.
Going to the wine
because I know you took over
your parents wine business.
- Yes.
- Explain to me why, first of all, why?
Why did you take it over?
Were they kind of over it
or you're just like hey I can do this?
- Hey I can do this and
my parents are the best
and I got to pay them back.
The story that most people
don't know about me is
I built that business from three to 60
and left with nothing.
- And why?
- Because it was my parent's business.
- So you just didn't care?
- I care, like let's not,
I don't want to front.
Like it feels a little weird.
You know, first of all I gave up my 20s.
- But the day you left,
you didn't say like hey--
- I was ready, I knew what
was about to come next.
- [Chris] You didn't want a dollar?
- I had no leverage like I
wasn't gonna roll up on pops
and be like yo, count me in now.
- [Chris] I would have rolled up on pop.
- The time to roll on up on
pops was in the beginning
but I'm an immigrant, I'm an immigrant.
Like you know, when
you're a white immigrant
people don't really
know your an immigrant.
I'm an immigrant, I wasn't born here.
And like here's family
immigrant businesses.
We have a business, whether
it's a bodega or liquor store
or 7-eleven or a car wash
or whatever the fuck it is,
we have a business and it's
mom and dad's until they die
and then you get the business.
That's the rules everybody,
but honestly that worked for me
because to be very frank,
my number one reason of going
into the family business was
I wanted to put them on
the way they put me on.
I didn't want to owe fucking
favors to my parents.
This is why I get so crazy
about the entitlement shit.
I went the other way.
I wanted to settle the
score with my parents
for putting a roof over my
head and taking me to America
from bullshit fucking Belarus.
So I was like let me just
fucking explode this for them.
That's how it evolved.
- And your relationship with them is good
and has always been good, right?
- Yeah but I would say and you
know, back to not fronting,
there was tension between me and my pops
because a couple things happened.
One, I'm building this huge
business and it's not mine,
that's weird and I would argue that
when I got into my late 20s and early 30s
that started to weigh
on me a little bit more.
Two, I started getting a lot of fame
in the liquor business like whiz kid.
And my dad and everyone's
like Gary, Gary, Gary store,
and that started fucking with my dad.
He's like yo, first of all it's my store.
Second of all like yo,
I came here with nothing
and like did something
like what happened to my part of the story
because it became wiz kid
does this and wiz kid does,
you know wasn't like it
is now with the whole
where I've really kind
of gotten some awareness.
It was in this little industry
but you know how it is.
- [Chris] That's your world.
- You just beat me to it.
It's your fucking world.
And so like 80 year old dudes
are rolling up on my pops
and be like man, your
kid really put you on.
- Oh, man. (chuckles)
- Yeah, you got it.
And my dad's got too
much pride for that shit.
I mean if anybody ever
rolls up on me in my life
and says my kids put me on,
I'm gonna punch that person in the face.
Like that doesn't play for me
and my dad and I share
a lot of competitive DNA
so luckily I had a lot
of empathy for my dad
and understood like yeah, I
wouldn't like that either.
So I was able to always kind
of swallow my pride at times
and then ultimately like my
brother was graduating college
and I was gonna start a business with him.
I made a really smart move
and took money I had saved
and one of the things
I did really well was
I lived humble as fuck.
I lived in a fucking one-bedroom apartment
in Springfield, New Jersey.
Didn't cost much.
I didn't get fancy moved to New York.
I never went out so really
easy to like save money
when you don't spend a
thousand bucks on a weekend
hitting it hard.
And I saved, I saved, I saved.
I didn't have a lot of
money but everything I had
I bet on Facebook and Twitter.
This is why I believe people can win.
I wasn't making a lot of money.
I was building business for somebody else.
I just lived humbly
like everybody wants...
some kid just tweeted,
I put out that tweet,
somebody else is like yeah.
Other kids are like easy
for you guys to say,
it was so much easier
into '70s, '80s, and '90s.
I'm like you're a fucking loser dick.
We didn't have Internet.
What the fuck do you know
about the '70s, '80s, and '90s?
You fucking suck bitch.
Like it's not easier you're
just lazy and entitled
'cause mommy and daddy
did everything for you
and you think life's
about playing fucking Xbox
and smoking weed and fucking
drinking Mountain Dew
you fucking asshole.
Go work.
- Yeah, let me ask you
this, what did you--
- I got so pissed. (laughs)
- I love it.
- I'm bringing the collateral
from the tweet I just subbed.
Everybody who's listening, I'm sorry.
16 minutes ago I saw that tweet,
I'm like this kid literally
thinks the '70s, '80s, and '90s
was harder, are you fucking kidding me?
The Internet's the best.
Every fucker listening
right now can go to Alibaba,
buy some bullshit, flip it on Amazon
and eBay and make money.
Every dick listening right
now has a thousand dollars
worth of fucking shit in their home
that they'll never use again.
Do you understand if you
put that dartboard on eBay,
you'd get seven bucks?
- [Chris] Yeah, absolutely.
But hey, I'm not the one in your tweets.
- I get it.
(laughing)
- But this is the other thing.
- I can't stop looking at
everything in this room.
- There's just a bunch of random shit.
- There's $8,000 in here.
'Cause those Nikes are
probably worth a fortune.
- Yeah, this place is like
a little eBay gold mine.
(laughing)
This is other thing I was gonna say is
you must get the worst of
all of those type of
social media comments.
You know what I'm saying?
- I get the best and the worst.
- True but because you're
exposing everyone's life.
Your ripping everyone's scabs off.
- The biggest reason a lot of
people don't like me at first
is I'm poking at the thing
they don't want anybody to know about.
- [Chris] And then it's
like fuck you dude.
- 100%.
- [Chris] You know how hard it is?
- Yep and I'm like I do
but like you dwelling
and blaming your parents,
your neighborhood,
society, the government,
it's not going to do anything for you.
Complaining and entitlement
is just like it's poison.
And so for me it's like and
this is why I get the best.
I get fucking DMs that make my head spin.
- Oh, I'm sure.
- Like yo, bro.
Shit like this.
Yo bro, so yeah I was hitting my girl
before I started watching your shit
and you've made me a better man
and I don't do that no more
and I make money the right way.
- [Chris] Do you respond to that?
- Yeah, I'm like all right
first of all like cool.
Never hit your girl again.
Two, like awesome and three,
like don't get flashy now
just 'cause you made
your first thousand bucks
flipping something on Craig's...
by the way do you know much money
I've made for people telling
them to go to Craigslist,
get shit for free, and then flip it?
- Wasn't that kind of the first big thing
that really broke through
to like the masses?
- You know what it was?
- It wasn't that, I will say this.
I was on The Breakfast Club.
- I remember that.
- And MB came at me and
he was like yo, whatever.
Like stop being like were,
like stop motivating me.
- I watched that.
- Give me something tangible
and I was like oh, fuck.
You know 'cause I was like you came at me.
Your brain goes fast and I'm like well,
the most tangible thing I know,
if I went to zero tomorrow.
Coma, my face got ripped
off, I have a new face,
I'm in Alaska, like what
the fuck just happened.
This is a nightmare?
No, this is my new life, cool.
I don't complain and the
first thing I do is like
I find shit to flip.
Like the number one thing that
gets everybody out of zero is
selling something and I
think like everybody wants to
build the next off-white.
And I'm like yo, before you
get to the next off-white,
before you tell me that
you're fucking gonna be
the next fucking champion,
why don't you learn how to go to Goodwill,
buy some T-shirts for a
dollar and sell them for 11
and get your shit together
'cause in your email
you also said that you have $17
and you want me to give you $10,000.
- [Chris] But that
thing just caught right?
That Breakfast Club clip was just--
- Caught.
- Yeah I mean, Breakfast Club no question
started the process.
It was interesting it was
happening in parallel.
Breakfast Club and I brought
Mike Boyd closer to my team,
not just at Vaynermedia
because I wanted to...
it's just to me the culture, music,
like I started listening
to more emerging artists.
It's amazing how it actually works.
Breakfast Club and me spending
a lot more time on SoundCloud
and you know, artists and just in general.
This sneaker thing was in the background
that I wanted to do with K-Swiss.
Like it was just like all happening
and Vayner's getting more mature
so I know I'm ready to buy shit.
So brands, I want to market to 15 to 30.
Youth keeps you young, I love it.
I feel younger at 42 than ever in my life
because I'm just in it.
It's cool, I like it.
- Yeah okay, so let me ask you this.
Back to the story part of it.
So you build this
business up to 60 million,
that's from like doing the YouTube stuff,
doing better marketing, right?
- Email, Google AdWords, even direct mail
and radio and television.
Just a great marketer, a great operator.
I'm a business man.
Vaynermedia, Manor acts
with PureWow and 137PM now,
That's a 200 million dollar
enterprise I built from scratch.
I'm a good businessman.
I think people forget that a little bit.
I like that part a little bit.
I think I like being underestimated
and I think the explosion of
Gary Vee in the last 18 months
has a lot of people under estimating
how much of a businessman I am.
Not just a personality.
- Yeah but that's gonna benefit you later.
- 100%.
And then you know what I'm just
gonna ask this question now,
it's one I wrote down.
One thing that you wrote that
I thought was really dope
or said or something was...
everyone said you were the
wine guy until you weren't.
What is everyone saying that you are now
that you're not?
- I think 50% of the people in the world
think I'm a motivational speaker.
- And how will they see you
differently in 10 years?
- That was one of the greatest
businessmen of all time
who happened to be motivational.
And honestly, let me
say it a different way.
I think I will be one of the...
most respected entrepreneurs ever.
And I'll tell you why.
I don't know if I'm gonna make
the most, let me rephrase.
I'm not gonna make the most money, right?
Elon Musk and Zucks and
Bezos and Meg Whitman,
there's tons of people that
are gonna do it bigger.
What I think I'm gonna do is
give back more to the game.
You know the people that are really in
the billionaire girls/boys club
they're not in the trenches like I am.
They're not spitting
fucking eBay flip tactics,
they're not doing podcast
because they know they're
gonna reach different people.
They're not in it.
They're in their ivory towers
in their fucking, you know,
This morning 6:00 a.m.
I did a little snap.
Just sitting at the airport.
I mean fucking a hundred people were like
yo, why don't you fly private?
Yo, don't you have a
fucking club membership
with all the miles you put in?
And I replied and I'm like I do.
I'm like but it's fine sitting here too.
Like I'm not fucking fancy.
- Do you think it keeps
you hungry because I also,
I'm gonna be honest.
I don't consider myself very fancy.
I've been doing this a long time.
Flying private is one of the things
I would just love to be able to do
and my question is do you
just feel the hunger more?
- Flying private is smart
because it's practical.
And I've definitely flown
private more in the last year
than I have in my whole life
because it saves me time
and time is valuable.
To me it's like if I
don't have to fly private,
I definitely don't, I'm not fucking,
who my fucking flying private for?
I'll be honest with you, how about this?
I flew to CAN private the
other day and it sucked
because the beds in first-class
American make a flat bed
and the private shit is kind of
still a little bit old school.
It was a fucking trillion-dollar plane
but it was still not a
fucking bed the way I liked it
and I was like fuck, I wish
I went fucking American.
- Yeah, I get it, I get it.
Okay so let me, sorry.
- Let me just stay on that one minute
'cause I have a great sense
of who listens to this.
If you were doing anything
because you give a fuck
about what the other
person's seeing it thinks,
you are losing.
- Agreed, it's not about for me--
- Period, that's it by the way.
- What?
- So if you're flying
private 'cause you love it,
Andy Frisella, a buddy
of mine, he loves lambos
and I know he does.
So I'm like good.
You win, right?
Like to me your point,
that's why I made that point.
If you want to fly private,
if you fly private because
your times become so valuable,
smart.
If you fly private because fuck it,
it makes you super happy.
Like your dream of dreams is like
this just makes me fucking
smile in my stomach.
Then good.
But if you fly private
because you want to put
that Instagram photo up
and you want to project a persona,
it's going in the wrong direction.
You're tied up in the wrong thing.
- And so you just genuinely
at the core of you
don't give a shit about this
being on an American lay flat?
- Not that part, right?
Like I give a shit about being liked
which is why people like me.
Like I genuinely give a
shit about being liked
so that's why I build a real community.
That's why I'm putting up good shit.
I genuinely don't want
to spend money on things
that I don't value.
So for example, if I value my health
like I did four years ago,
I have a full-time trainer,
he flies with me.
It cost me money to fly my trainer to LA
and workout this morning at
fucking Equinox like I did.
I'm spending money but
I'm spending money on
what matters to me and for example,
I don't even talk that much about
having a trainer that travels with me.
I have a funny feeling the people
I'm referencing in this thing,
if they had a trainer traveling with them,
they'd have a post of that every time
and be like hey, Rick, wasn't
awesome to be in Mexico?
I paid for Rick to be in
Mexico because I'm a baller,
you fucking asshole.
- So obviously undeniably
you're one of the best,
the best at this new media style of
even being an entrepreneur.
- [Gary] Yes.
- And documenting and connecting
and you know what I'm saying?
- [Gary] Yes.
- When you started this did
you have this grand plan
or was it like this just
needs to be documented
and this whole thing kind of snowballed?
- DRock reached out to
me, wanted to make a film,
I was ready, Vayner was finally in a place
where I was ready to make content again
because in 2012 to 14 I
was kind of head down.
DRock hits me up, he's like
I wanna make a film for you.
I'm like you know what?
Yeah, cool, let's do it.
Makes a film, I really like it.
I really like him, he's a good kid.
I'm like you know what?
I've been dying to do this Q&A show.
I loved speaking, speaking
was working for me
and I was like you know what would be rad?
If I just did Q&A.
'Cause that's where I'm my best.
Like if you asked me where
I'm at my best. it's Q&A.
So I was like man, I'm
gonna do a show about Q&A
that may parlay into me being
able to just do Q&A keynotes.
That was the master plan.
So I hired DRock full time.
We start a youtube show
called the #AskGaryVee show
and it starts popping a little bit.
At the same token Casey and others
have the vlog thing going.
First person.
And DRock's like one of these
fucking you know video nerds
like Babin and all these fucking
kids, they love this shit.
They grew up with it, they love Casey,
they love all the shit.
And he's like you have to do
this, you have do something.
I'm like dude I'm not
fucking walking around
with a camera in my hand.
And somewhere, somehow, some moment,
I'm like you should follow me around.
And I remember sitting on
it actually for a little bit
'cause I said oh, that's super douchey.
Like am I really gonna go
like reality TV on the world
without like really doing reality TV?
I'm like that may not play
but then finally back
to not giving a fuck.
I was like I'm gonna be right
and a lot of people gonna
do this in two years
and you just did it for me.
You literally, literally in
the start of this episode
did what I knew would
happen three years ago
which is I'm gonna get
credit for starting a trend
that everybody's gonna do
because it makes sense.
It's a good idea.
And let me tell you why.
It's not just a good idea
for building your brand
and all that, it's a good idea
'cause it's gonna be fun to
look at when you're fucking old.
Like I can't wait to watch fucking,
when Babin's 73 and looks like dog shit,
I'll be like dude you were so young at 20.
Look at you, you're fucking amazing.
You know, it's gonna be...
I mean all the cool shit
I did in 2005 to 2010,
I spoke to Facebook when
there was 300 employees.
That'd be cool to reference.
I was super right about Instagram
being a steal for a billion dollars.
I have one lucky moment on CNN
where I'm like talking that shit
but I would have had three
months of talking that shit.
You know like I'm gonna be
right about voice, right?
And in seven years when voice
and everybody's trying to
figure out their voice strategy
and their Alexa Skills and all that,
I'll be like yo, look
at the recall in 2018
when I fucking predicted this shit.
And then people will be like oh, fuck.
Like it just works and then most of all,
my grandkids are gonna
be like hey grandpa,
you know Gary, I talk like
you or I have that mannerism
or I make that smirk
or that's why little Sally
fucking does that thing
and that's just, like why do we like
looking at pictures of our grandparents?
This is way better.
- Yeah, I get it.
Let's just paint a picture of
one day you're a billionaire,
you're the owner of the
Jets, you're up in the box.
killing it, is Babin with you vlogging it?
- Yeah but it probably won't be Babin
'cause Babin is probably gonna be
accepting his third Academy Award.
- Sure, the next Babin.
I'm saying are you vlogging,
are you vlogging from
now until your funeral?
- Yes, I think so.
I mean look, anything can
happen, something bad.
Something tragic can happen in my life.
My mom could tragically die tomorrow
and I might just shut down for
a while or who knows, right?
Or something new happens or what have you
but I see non-business value in vlogging.
I see personal family
heritage shit, you know?
- How do you get to the billion dollar,
multi-billion dollar Jets owner?
I guess what I'm saying is--
- [Gary] How am I planning on doing it?
- From my perspective, right?
And this is really another one
like my questions to you is
I see what you're doing kind of
and you have all of these
different things from the agency
to the new companies to whatever
and you now have this
added icing level of fame
for lack of a better word and connection.
What do you do to take that to that level?
- I buy Prince, the
tennis racquet business.
I convert it into a
sneaker and hoodie brand.
I run it through the Vayner
and Gary Vee machine.
I buy it for 208 million
because now I'm building big
businesses, I can afford it.
And I sell it for 2.7 billion to Adidas
'cause they need the
more contemporary brand.
I buy Cracker Jacks for a hundred million,
I flip it for a billion.
I think the what I did smart was
I deployed self-awareness eight years ago
and said I have to build a machine
that's the scalable version of me
so that when I buy Smart
Water on the decline,
when I buy Rolling Rock the beer,
when I buy this shit, this thing,
that I will become the CEO of.
So my executives at Vaynard,
somebody will become the CEO, right?
Andre will become the CEO.
Marcus, Jeff, like
somebody's gonna become a CEO
and then I will be the CEO of a business
that I buy for a couple hundred million
that I will sell for two billion
and I'll be off to the races.
- [Chris] Is that what PureWow is for you?
PureWow was actually part of the machine.
So that's publishing, right?
137PM now, a male's brand,
that's part of the machine
because I'll use those entities to vig
whatever the fuck I care about.
- So there's no brand yet?
And what do you know now?
Are you constantly looking right now?
- Yeah but everything's expensive
because the economy's too fluffy.
I need everybody to go
work at Citibank, got it?
- Yeah.
- I'm like a snake in the grass right now
which is crazy 'cause I'm
loud as fuck right now
but in my head, I'm incognito right now.
Which is why I know I've won.
If everybody thinks I've
won or I'm winning right now
and I think I'm dog shit right now
and I'm still laying low
and I'm just jockeying and
putting the pieces together,
well then I'm fucking coming
out like a phoenix in 2025.
- That's why I see it, from
my perspective I see it
and obviously we've been involved in TV
and all these different things, right?
So I see what you've done,
I see the platform you've now built.
I see it not as at the height,
I see it as like all right,
you're lined up to do the thing.
What is it going to be?
I can't wait to see the next.
- And it might be IP.
You know, like I might buy like Snorks.
Remember Snorks?
Those fucking like, you gotta be old kids.
Most of people listening now
like gonna have to Google it.
Snorks were like under the
water Smurfs back in '84.
- [Chris] The cartoon?
- Yeah.
So I'm gonna buy some old IP maybe.
I don't know but I'm gonna
buy something and flip it.
- [Chris] Got it.
- 'Cause that's what I do.
Whether it's buying fucking He-man toys
for eight bucks at a garage
sale and flipping it for 42
or buying some wine and
flipping it or baseball cards.
That's what I do.
I'm just gonna have one big fucking flip.
- Another big one I think
a lot of people know
and then will wrap it up after this is
the one thing is you don't...
you vlog your fucking ass off.
You are constantly creating content
but you can tell there's a
massive side of your life
that doesn't show.
- [Gary] My family.
- Family, right.
It like you're working all day
but when the clock is up it's time to go.
You wrap it up you go home
and you're just father Gary.
- Well, no.
On the weekends and seven weeks vacation
but Monday through Friday
I'm getting home at 11:30 at night.
There is no father Gary.
- So they just know to
wait until the weekend.
- Yeah, we're playing an extreme game,
at least that's what it is now.
It works for me and my family,
working for my wife's family,
so it's a little bit more native to us.
I'm sure for some people that's crazy.
I respect that, everybody
should do it their way.
So that's what's going on
and then on the flip side
we're not showing the family
because we made a family
decision that my wife and kids
like we're gonna keep that separate
and it's already been hard
because I'm getting recognized
so much more in public
when I'm with them but it's definitely...
it's been very conscious.
- And that doesn't bother you?
The one thing that kills me
or gets me is you're going to,
everywhere you go you're doing meetups.
Like it seems like you
genuinely love the energy,
the connection, that you don't get tired?
You don't get worn out of like man,
I just want to go to
the mall with my family
and not be recognized.
- No.
- You don't?
- I really like...
Babin, right, that's
the coolest part right?
Like I get more energy.
100%, right?
- [Babin] Yeah, I mean it's
always like at the end of
the longest days, someone can roll up,
and you just immediately like...
- Yeah, it's tough man.
I've even had times where I'm
like I love you but like--
- You know what, because I'm grateful.
I can't get over the gratitude.
Like there's no tired or annoyed
or struggling with something
that person doesn't know about
that trumps the gratitude
of somebody being like
holy shit, you're Gary Vee.
You have to understand a very
important thing about me.
My micro fame, emerging fame,
comes not because I'm fucking hot.
Not because I can spit bars.
Not because I can put a ball in a hoop.
My fame is coming because
I'm bringing people
emotional and mental
value that then maybe,
maybe they act on which then
makes their life better.
There is a different level of relationship
and it's nice.
If you like me, I've done
something nice for you.
I've gotten you to be less insecure.
I've gotten you to
finally tell your parents
to go fuck themselves.
I've gotten you to like do the thing
you've been dying to do.
I've gotten you to put your
situation in perspective.
Here's my big thing.
If you've heard me, you're
already in a good spot.
Like if you've ever heard me
it means you have Internet.
(laughing)
- [Chris] True, probably a nice iPhone.
- You have a smartphone.
Like go sell your phone, like you know?
So you're already in a decent spot
and so my big thing is perspective.
Like you could be dead, you
could be not alive at all.
You could like whatever...
My mom and I appreciate,
I know I'm in a hard stop
but I'm enjoying it now so I'll give us
a couple more minutes, I
appreciate you your energy.
My mom lost her mom when she was five.
Her mom died.
My mom was being raised
in the Soviet Union.
Let me just break it down for everybody.
Bad, like bad.
19 fucking 62 Soviet Union, it's bad.
Like I know Mississippi's bad.
I know there's a lot of places
that are bad in America.
It's bad.
Like Stalin was killing everybody.
Like killing everybody, okay?
Next, her dad then goes
to jail for a decade
for being Jewish.
That's how it rolled in the Soviet Union.
Listen we got real fucking race problems
and gender problems in America.
Forget about Supreme Court,
you're mad at them right now
or all this other shit.
Like in Russia you just got
scooped up and sent to Siberia.
So now her dad's ghost.
She's also living in one of the
small Jewish towns in Russia
post-World War II where
everybody blamed Jews
for World War II.
So all the millions that
died, yeah that's your fault.
And Grandpa after he lost his wife,
after my mom lost her mom,
he goes a little bit like gangster
and marries like a young non-Jewish girl,
which is like a scandal in all of town.
So now mom lost her mom, dad's in jail,
and she's being raised
by young non-Jewish woman
which ostracizes her from
the whole environment
and her five year older brother
is really her five year
younger brother, right?
My mom then has a kid at 20,
moves to America with nothing,
her husband has to work the
next 15 years every minute,
never sees him and raises
three kids with no help.
We go on one family
vacation my whole life,
my mom never complained once.
So when I sit here I'm
like why do I get so pissed
that people complain and by the way,
Babin you've been with me,
I've never really said this in this way
so I'm glad I'm saying on your podcast
because I'm going to point to it
and make sure everybody listens.
Now I know why I hate complaining
because if my mom doesn't
complain, who the fuck are you?
- Yeah and you've always been that way?
- And I've always been that
way without realizing it.
Got it?
Because who the fuck's
psychoanalyzing themselves
in their teen or 20s.
- When did you realize it,
when all this attention started coming
and people started saying
how come you're so positive?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I started, you know in
the last five seven years
I'm like wait a minute, the
why am I connecting like this?
What the fuck?
Am I Oprah?
Like you know?
Fuck I'm Oprah, god damn it.
And I push against it which is good
like I don't want to make
my money on my audience,
which is the biggest
thing that happened to me
was that I knew how to make money
outside of the people that listened to me.
Which is game-changing.
Which is why people fuck with me.
They know I don't want their money.
I want their attention
for a very limited time
so I can reframe their fucking brain
to make them realize how good it is
and how capable they are.
I want to basically undo all
the bullshit their parents
and friends did to give them insecurity.
Shed some light on yo,
you're mad that you
fucking went to college
and can't get a job?
What about going to Kmart,
buying things on closeout,
and selling it on eBay?
Like I'm not joking about this.
You know like I think people,
like I don't think
people really understand
how deeply religious I am about this
which is you are 100% in control.
You don't like America?
Move to Sweden.
- [Chris] Yeah, I get it.
And you know what's funny?
- It's very real my man.
- I get it more sitting
and talking to you, right?
- Interesting, why?
- Because I watch a lot of your stuff
and I really like a lot of it.
- I appreciate it.
I know you give love which I appreciate.
- I do and--
- And real life it just, you can--
- No, I'm not saying, I
don't want to come off wrong.
I'm not saying I've ever questioned it
and said oh, like this a front?
- But it closed the final dot?
- But when you sit and talk with you,
you can tell that, it's not a character.
You know what I'm saying?
Something about just actually
the way that you say it.
- Babin, that's what
everybody asks you, right?
Like am I real in real life?
That's the number one question, right?
- Well sure, I bet, I can see why
but I'm just saying that I think that
really sitting and talking
you it's like damn,
like you genuinely, it's in your eyes,
it's in the way, you know I mean?
- You know what's really cool?
My high school junior
high college friends,
they're the most excited
'cause they're like man,
you were like this when
there was none of this.
Meaning like before the Internet,
like you were the nicest
kid in our junior high
trying to like amp up the
biggest nerd in our...
like this is real stories I get.
Like this is weird.
Like you were just nice
and you didn't give a fuck.
Like you took Ls from
popular kids to protect nerds
'cause wow, you actually...
Oh, now I get it.
You didn't give a fuck.
And to me like life now is
way easier than high school.
You know when this shit was hard?
When the high school ecosystem
didn't reward kindness.
- [Chris] Yeah, high school sucks.
- High school sucks and there's hierarchy
but I spit in the face
of the most popular kids
in my high school.
First of all, they liked me.
'Cause I liked them but
anytime they went to that place
where they weren't nice,
and I wasn't tough, it wasn't
like I was gonna fight.
I would just make snarky comments back
like I knew how to play
psychological warfare.
You know what I mean?
- That's clear.
- I knew how to poke their insecurities.
Like you're mad at Joel because
Becky broke up with you.
And then everybody's like oh!
You know what's good about high school is
you could swing it quick, you know?
- What about, can I ask you another one?
- Yeah, go ahead.
- To me it appears that the case with you
is outside of your bigger strategy.
- Outside of my bigger strategy?
- Meaning right, if
your bigger strategy is
building this up, not worrying
about monetizing fans,
but bringing on brands,
building up whatever.
What was the strategy behind--
- It's the preview.
- It's just to see if you could do it?
- Of course.
It's the preview.
- And you, yeah, yeah.
- K-Swiss was fucking,
will go down as a thing
that everybody looks back at
and be like oh shit, he was
cutting his teeth on that.
- So for you that's
like can I sell product?
- 100%.
But not me, it.
Meaning Gary Vee, yeah,
but K-Swiss is getting lifted overall.
- Yeah, I get it.
That's just a question I
had 'cause I watch that.
I'm trying to obviously--
- And you know why I did it with K-Swiss?
'Cause they were at zero.
- Did you take equity?
- Nope.
I didn't even need to make a good deal.
I needed to see...
like if I did it with something
that was further along
I wouldn't have been able to
unwind if it was my impact
or if it was just cruising.
Got it?
- [Chris] Yeah.
- So I had to go with
something that gave me freedom
and really was gonna bank on me.
- Yeah because I feel
like you deserve equity
and you know what else is airpods.
I see so many fake Gary
Vees with airpods man,
it is incredible.
- I will tell you those are the fun things
about documenting.
If you look at the early
days, I had airpods day one,
everyone's shitting on them.
I'm co-signing it heavy
and now everybody's fucking doing it.
- There's so many beanies and airpods
with the the cameraman walking by.
- By the way and you know
what's crazy about that?
It's just that most
like I'm just like what?
Because I never pandered
to cool my whole life,
back to high school and everything,
to watch nuances of cool.
And I don't think I'm the coolest
but I definitely understand
what's happening.
- [Chris] But bro, you're cool.
- I'm like why am I
cool, it's like so fun.
- [Chris] It lined up.
- No, I know it's really cool.
- [Chris] Okay this is the end then.
- Yeah, go ahead.
- I'm gonna flip this in
a different way for you.
You do #AskGaryVee.
- [Gary] Yes.
- People call in, they ask
you all sorts questions,
wanting you to turn their life around.
Let's just go back in
time, your young Gary Vee
running around New Jersey
flipping lemonade stands,
doing all this shit.
You call #AskGaryVee and say hey man,
is there anything you can tell me,
like I'm really hungry out here.
I really want to be a
big-league entrepreneur.
What do I do?
What takes the edge off
of some of my extra worry,
what can you tell me old Gary?
- So a couple things.
You know what I wish is I lived in the era
where chemicals in one's body
were readable in real time.
- [Chris] Say it again.
- Yeah, I'm gonna say
it really nice and slow
because I know it's weird as fuck.
If you knew what was happening in my body
as you were asking that question.
I could feel the warmth of my chemicals.
The thought that young Gary
would ever call old Gary is inconceivable.
- [Chris] Why?
- 'Cause young Gary didn't want
to take advice from anybody.
There was no insecurities.
It was 100% tilt, I know
what the fuck I'm doing,
no one's my mentor, the game is my mentor.
The process is my mentor.
- [Chris] You still feel that way?
- 100%.
I learn by doing.
I don't need somebody's advice.
Not my dad's, not my mom's,
not fucking Elon Musk,
not fucking Warren Buffett.
I don't want it.
I'll tell you why.
Not because I don't fucking respect it.
I respect anybody that's...
I respect anyone who's trying.
For everybody out there
who's trying, I respect you.
It's not how I learn.
The reason I am who I am
is I listen to people.
- [Chris] Meaning feedback?
- 100%.
The reason I love that person
rolling up at me, Babin,
at 11:37 p.m. after a fucking 23 hour day
is 'cause I'm gonna learn something
from the way they feel and
what are they gonna say.
Why do they fuck with me?
The reason I read all
my comments and engage
and I know what to make.
Do you know why I know how to
make the next piece of content?
They told me.
It's in my comments.
It's in everyone's comments
but all these fuck faces
listening right now
care more about the likes people give them
than the people behind those likes.
And that is the fucking mistake.
- There it is man, I'll
let you get out of here.
(laughing)
Good solid ending.
- Love it.
- Thank you Gary, I appreciate it.
(upbeat music)